It is my pleasure to
have here with us today,
Ravi Auger Wall to discuss his new book,
uh,
into your connected how the smartphone
revolution is transforming the world's
largest democracy.
Mr Ogre Wall is currently the managing
editor of foreign policy magazine.
Before that, he spent more than a decade
with CNN where he worked in New York,
London, and most recently in New Delhi
where he was the region's bureau chief.
The book has received quite a
bit of praise already for reads.
Acarya calls it quite simply the best
book about India Today. Nicholas Thompson,
the editor in chief of wired magazine
says the story of how India got wired is
one of the most important
in the world today.
And you won't find a better
guide than Ravi occur wall.
That conversation couldn't be more
important for us here at Google, uh,
to embrace robustly just given the fact
that we are one of the key drivers of
the smartphone revolution.
80% of the smartphones in
India are android smartphones.
So I don't think we can be thoughtful
enough about ensuring that our products
and technologies not only help build
a more technologically enabled India,
but a better India.
And to unpack the,
still discuss that even further. Um,
I'll bring grubby up on the stage.
I want to start off with,
with the smartphone revolution,
you talk about how in two thousand twenty
million Indians were connected to the
Internet, uh, in 2017, that
number was 465 million.
And your project in 2025 that, that
number is going to be more than a billion.
And you,
you talk about the ways in which that's
similar to kind of the advent of the
automobile and the transformational impact
that it had here in the United States
from kind of the creation of suburbia,
the interstate highway to where, uh,
very often someone got their first
kiss longer weekends hub, all sorts of,
kind of tremendous impacts.
And you talk about how the smartphone
is doing the same in India,
which makes it not just simply an
evolution as it's been here in the United
States,
but a revolution.
So we'd love for you to kind of talk
about how India got here to this moment.
Where is it right now and where do you
anticipate it's going to be 10 years from
now as a result of the
smartphone revolution?
That's a great question. Thank
you for having me. Thank you.
All of you for attending.
And really it's,
it's very special for me to come
speak at Google and as Ron said,
Google is playing such a huge role and
the growth of the Internet in India and
in fact expanding the pie
of Internet users in India.
So to begin with,
you at your first point about how India
is going through a smartphone revolution,
the reason why I use the word revolution
in the book, and I don't use it lightly,
is to contrast it with the
way in which the West has.
People in the West have discovered the
internet. So for of you in this room,
you know,
my assumption would be that you know,
sometime in the late 1990s you had a
PC and a telephone land line and then
you've got a dial up internet connection
and then you evolved from there to a
DSL and cable broadband. And then
you've got your routers, you had Wifi,
and then eventually you have three g on
the phone for g and a phone and you are
where you are today. Um, in India,
a very small slice of Indians
who were rich, privileged,
usually urban, often male, um,
had access to those things.
Only 2% of Indians had access to
telephone landlines in the year 2000.
A similar percentage of Indians had access
to pcs and that's why there were only
20 million Indians online in the year
2000 and the numbers then begin to jump
very rapidly. In 2010, there were
100 million Indians online. By 2015,
there were 300 million Indians online
and now we're crossing off a billion.
The projections are that it'll reach
800 million by 2025 and then a billion
shortly thereafter. All of this growth
is going to come from smartphones. Um,
why? Because smartphones in India are
very cheap. They are easily accessible.
They are for most Indians,
not just a smartphone as it is for
you guys here. For most Indians,
the smartphone is their first camera.
It is their first screen.
It is also their first Walkman,
an MP three player.
It is a first of many things in one device
and that's why it's as transformative
as it is for most Indians. This is a
gateway to many forms of technology.
All of it in one go. You could
be illiterate in India. Um,
and you can still speak to
your phone. Uh, you, you know,
the old Internet was mostly
for English speakers in India.
The new Internet is for people
who speak, uh, you know,
a multitude of Indian languages
and thanks to Google in part,
those languages are all now
accessible on the internet. Um,
there's a great analogy with
the car which you brought up.
And I like to compare the moment that
India is going through right now to the
moment that America went through
a century ago. So, you know,
America invented the car and with the car
you created roads and highways and the
interstate system.
And then with that,
tens of thousands of jobs are created
and America built suburbia and the picket
fence home.
And with that you have the commute.
And along the commute you needed
to create an infrastructure.
So that infrastructure was gas stations
and multiplexes and movie theaters and
the drive in restaurant.
And so much more the seven eleven's think
of all of those things as a national
infrastructure across the country.
And it wasn't just that there was a
cultural and an imaginative infrastructure
as well. I mean, for most Americans,
the car was their first private property.
It was literally a tool
of mobility. It was, uh,
the vehicle in which they sort of
injected their dreams and their ambitions.
You know, for the baby boomer generation
in Hollywood, it was enshrined, I mean,
think of the race and the
chase and the bank heist.
Every Hollywood movie of a certain
era was defined around the car,
the car defined Americans.
I mean if you drove a pickup
truck or a sedan or a hatchback,
it kind of explained who you
were and where you were headed.
Take all of those things
and transpose it to India.
Today the smartphone defines who you are.
You an iPhone person and therefore do
you have $1,200 to spend on a phone?
Likely not in India. And
being, because as we know,
apple hasn't been able to make
serious inroads into India. Um,
but the phone says a lot more about
who you are. And by the same token,
the phone is creating an entire
infrastructure of payments,
of communication. It's
building trust, um, with maps,
with education,
with various tools that people are using.
Um,
for all of those reasons for a country
that is as young as India is average age,
27,
average income less than $2,000 a year,
you take all of those things together
for country that's marching and on the
rise. And the thesis of my
book is that this one device,
this one tool will end up being
incredibly transformative for the country.
That's no,
and I,
I think one of those stories that you
start the book off that really illustrates
that compellingly as the
story of pool with you, uh,
who is a Google saute and you can explain
what that is. Um, I have to admit,
I fell a little bit in love with
Paul with a reading about her.
She's like on her bicycle
going around rural Rajasthan,
introducing the Internet for the first
time to, uh, to women in these villages.
Would love for you to kind of talk about
how you first found her, her story,
and then what kind of broader lessons
we can draw about her example.
Uh, and the penetration of India
should not only for women, but for,
for rural communities.
Sure. It's so great to talk
about food. Let the hair,
cause I'm coming full circle.
I found [inaudible] through Google.
Um, and not the search engine,
but literally threw
people at Google who said,
you must take a look at Google Southie
and you must look into this story.
And so I did. Um, for those of you
don't know, Google Southie is a program,
uh,
at Google where Google is partnered
with many NGOs across the country.
And it is, um, uh, giving, uh,
first of all it's training rural women
how to use the internet and then it's
arming them with,
uh,
smartphones and tablets and a bicycle
to then go out into other villages,
teach and train other women
how to use the Internet,
how to familiarize themselves with the
Internet. Why is this important? Well, um,
you might remember when
I was starting off,
I said the old Internet in
India was urban, elite and male.
Uh, it was also English. Um, and
the reason why I say mail is that,
uh, even in 2014, uh,
about 70% of internet
users in India were male.
30% were women in villages.
Uh,
only one out of 10
Internet users were women.
And so the big gap was rural
women and women more nationally.
Google obviously, you know,
and you guys work on this,
realize that this was a great market to
tab and not just for economic reasons,
but also for humanitarian reasons.
And so the southeast,
what they've been doing is,
is in a sort of peer to
peer conversational way,
have been able to train other
rural women to use the Internet.
And the reason why this
is important again,
is that illiteracy is rife in
these parts of India. Um, you know,
in Roger Stone, the state in
which I met fool with the, um,
female literacy rates are about 50%,
which means there are all these women
who cannot read or write anything at all.
And so the Internet for them was always
going to be a thing that they could
never dream of using, not on a PC, not
on a phone, not on a regular phone.
And voice technology changed
all of that food with the, uh,
and I begin the book with
her speaking to some,
some other villages and she says,
uh, you know, all us, this thing,
Google asked something and most of them
don't know what to ask. I mean, you know,
and then one woman says, well, um,
you know, show us the Taj Mahal.
And a video pops up. Uh, she
says it in Hindi. She says,
Mojay Taj Mahal,
the cow and a video pops
up and they press play.
And for the first time they see moving
imagery of this monument that they have
all grown up as knowing as the
most beautiful thing in India.
It was a very profound moving moment
for me as well to see that. And, uh,
it gives you a sense of,
of,
of how technology really can break through
so many of the boundaries that we've
built in India,
not just gender,
but also costs and geography
and language and literacy.
Um, and fool with the was, uh,
if you read the book was just a great
example of a woman who was completely in
debatable and spirit. And, uh, you know,
was able to venture out into all these
villages and very enthusiastically be
sort of a, an internet evangelist,
uh, or Google evangelist.
Uh, and she was paid only a very
small amount of money, uh, to do this,
but was doing it mostly because she, she
was really excited about the project. Um,
for those of you been to
India, you know, it's,
it's quite rare to see women on bicycles
wearing a full sorry and heading out
into the villages and you know, the
southeast are doing just that, uh,
which is a real testament to
their enthusiasm for the Internet.
Yeah. And it's, it's what's, what
was interesting about her cases, you,
you talk about the fact that she had a
husband that was like very supportive of,
of what she was doing,
which enabled her to be
such an enthusiastic kind
of ambassador for the Sati
program. Uh, there was a quote in the
book where you talk about, you brought up,
cast you where you talk about how Carl
Marx and the 1850 [inaudible] thought
that the railroad was going to get
rid of the caste system in India. Um,
and there've been all
sorts of technologies since
then that have been like,
this is the vanguard of like maybe
pushing against some of these more ancient
social or cultural systems. Uh,
and those obviously failed. Um,
but you feel more bullish
about the smartphone. Um,
what's different about the smartphone
that you feel is going to break through
some of these more, uh, older
kind of patriarchal systems?
So I am more bullish.
Um,
there are still obstacles,
for example,
their entire villages in India where
the smartphone is banned for women. Uh,
and I go to one of these villages in good
drive and the men I spoke to their, uh,
sad that, you know, women just can't
use this. They're not smart enough.
They don't have the, they, they, they're
not capable of dealing with the Internet.
And,
and really what they were trying to tell
me without saying it in as many words,
is that they were frightened of what it
would mean to give women access to the
Internet. They were frightened of
what it meant to give women freedom.
You know, they had built
around, um, in fact,
entire societies were
built around, uh, you know,
patriarchal systems where women had
very little agency. And so in a sense,
one of the greatest obstacles to
allowing the Internet to reach,
uh, all Indians is his men and
mostly rural land. But that sad.
Um,
I think the reason why I'm more
bullish about the phone than any other
technology is that the phone is a
catalyst and it's coming at a moment when,
so first of all, it is cheap. It is
accessible, it is aspirational. Um,
but it's coming along with
a range of other forces.
There's a confluence of events at play
and those events are globalization,
cheap technology, the creation
of smartphones, which,
you know, let's face it,
our unprecedentedly,
you know,
compact and powerful and able to take
all of these things into one device,
all of these other devices
into one device. Um,
but also rising income levels in India.
The ability for a bigger Indian
companies to take big decisions,
set up big infrastructural projects.
You may have heard of reliance Geo,
which is a company that you know for
the first six months of its launch
essentially made data free in India.
So if you look at all of
those things together,
we're at a moment fairly unprecedented
in India's history where the smartphone
is just perfectly poised to reach so
many people and to give them all these
different things in one goal that
we're not going to happen organically.
Your PC is we're not going to
reach a majority of Indians,
organically cameras. We're not going to
reach a majority of Indians organically,
but you put it into one device.
You put all of these things in one
device at a very low price point. A Geo,
for example, leases out a very,
you know, it's a very basic phone,
but it's kind of a smartphone for $23.
Uh,
it's a three year lease for $23.
You can buy a certain Chinese
and Indian made phones, um,
for somewhere between 50 and $150.
Now at that price point,
when you include all of these things,
it's irresistible.
What are the,
the kind of gaps that you talk about the
smart phone being able to bridges the
urban rural gap, but also kind of the
linguistic gap to your point earlier,
the mobile phone is primarily been,
um,
or the smart phone and PC before that was
primarily targeted an English speaking
audience. And that's,
that started to change.
I think one of the stories that
really illustrates that is, uh,
the story of a uphill who started this
education app. But tell us about that.
Sure. Um, so, uh,
I have a chapter on education
and one of the, the,
the people that I profile in that chapter,
his name is Abdullah. Why here? Then he,
uh, he's a real sort of fixer
upper of a character. Uh,
didn't go to an English school growing up,
so he never really spoke English well.
And, you know, in India to
succeed, uh, you, you know,
speaking English is a
huge leg up. And, um,
so he started using an
app called Hello English,
which is one of India's top
educational apps. And, uh,
the way hello English works is as long
as you speak some other Indian language,
say Hindi,
and you can read the English alphabet,
you're able to then play these games
that teach you or help you improve your
conversational English. And so [inaudible]
was playing this game every day,
sitting on the toilet seat,
sitting in traffic jams,
and he got better and better and better.
And he was ranked number one out
of millions of, of users worldwide.
And so I found him and
sort of profiled him.
And His story was amazing because
he essentially became a confident,
a man and a confident teacher.
He runs a coaching institute in
Rajasthan through not only hello English,
this app, because he couldn't afford,
was that a stone going to a school?
Um, but he also became
a, you know, through,
through youtube and watching videos of
motivational speakers and stuff like
that. He just was able to become
a very confident educator. And,
and that struck me as, as you
know, the kind of thing that,
that it's hard to quantify
nationally. Like there's no, you know,
metric to look at those kinds of
intangible improvements in people's lives.
But also in that chapter, um, uh,
I also looked at learning outcomes for,
for children because I think if you look
at the biggest space for disruption in
India really is early childhood education.
Um,
and the reason is that, you know,
India has opened a lot of schools,
but the schools don't always train
people in the right way. Uh, and they're,
all of these studies that show that
learning outcomes for children was greatly
reduced after the age of Seven,
eight,
which meant that the reason why they were
dropping off and math and literacy is
because frankly they couldn't read,
they couldn't read and write,
and so they weren't able
to progress further.
And there's a lot of research now and
there are many Ngo's that are working in
this space,
but the phone is really come through
as a tool that could allow people to,
uh, improve their basic numeracy and
literacy, uh, at the lowest levels,
which would really work at a
mass way to Indians advantage.
I wanted to kind of take a step back and
kind of think about some of the macro
trends that have enabled a lot of the
evolutions that you discuss in the book.
Um,
it strikes me with the kind of analogy
of the automobile that it required a
robust partnership between the state and
private companies to get that right and
kind of the state knowing when to
lean in and when to lean back. Um,
at the end of the book,
you actually do a really good job of,
of framing up that narrative
and the context of the,
of mobile phones in India.
There's like an Indian
American businessmen who has
a conversation with Roger,
have gone the, uh, to kind of really pave
the way to bring, um, telephones to India,
which was a luxury as late
as a, as the early 1980s. Um,
we'd love for you to kind of
talk about that evolution,
particularly with an eye towards what is,
what is the right way that kind of
private forces and public institutions can
work together to really take advantage
and bring to fruition the potential of
these new technologies.
You know,
the telephony in India has mostly
been a private sector story.
So the public sector story was what you
were describing of the 60 seventies,
early eighties of the state trying to
get basic telephone landlines to people.
And that was something that
the state largely failed at.
And one innovation that really worked
for the state was when they opened what
was known as these STD, PCO, boots.
And these were basically,
um, telephone boots,
but they were manned by shopkeepers or
a seven 11 mom and pop store owners.
Uh,
they're basically at marketplaces
and you would go in and you could,
uh, uh, you know, pay for a metered call,
a local or international
as the case would be.
And that allowed many people to get
access to telephony in a way that they
wouldn't have otherwise. But you
know, in terms of mobile telephony,
when the state first, uh,
began to sort of, uh, you know,
open up and that sense, uh,
they, there were still many,
many restrictions for the private
sector and it was through sheer, um,
sort of, uh, you know,
force of will in the form of the
private sector that, you know,
three g and four g finally
took off in India. Um,
basically through advertising and offers
from the private sector that allowed it
to reach Indians in a mass way. And then
the second wave was through hardware.
So, you know, the, the handsets
and, and cheaper smartphones,
all of which are led by the
private sector in India. Um,
I think the space we're at now is,
you know,
the government has largely seeded a lot
of this space to the private sector,
but I think where the government
could be very important, uh,
and where the private sector could
work closely with the government, uh,
on his is regulation in terms of, you
know, how to regulate this market,
how to regulate the
entrance of new players,
how to regulate foreign
players versus Indian players.
But then the second thing that is very
important to me and is really a large
part of the book as well,
is to,
to sort of deal with some
of the adverse effects of,
of the smartphone boom in India and those
range from addictions to fake news to
pornography and two,
and we can get into some
more detail on those topics.
But just to use the analogy with the car,
once again,
you know, governments around the
world and the private sector, uh,
partnered on cars,
um,
with advertising basically in,
in terms of telling people that the
car is clearly a tool for immense good,
but it is also a weapon
of mass destruction.
So you need to not drink and drive,
you need to wear seatbelts
when you're driving.
And those were public interest campaigns
that were very important I think for
societies around the world.
And I've begun to see smartphones is
something quite similar to the car in that
respect, where, you know,
smartphones and technology can also
be immensely destructive to societies,
especially a society like
India, which is, you know,
still so nascent and gullible
and so many ways. Um,
but superstitions in,
in,
in various communities and the notion
of being able to see this device as
something that has immense potential
for good but also for bad and what to do
with that and how to deal
with that is very important.
And I think that's a space that uh, public
and private can really cooperate on.
Yeah,
I think that's a great segue into what
I'd love for us to unpack a little bit
more. Um, the,
the first part of the book is very
much about the opportunities of the
smartphone revolution in
education and healthcare and um,
empowering women all across the country.
I think the second part is when
you talk about some of, uh,
some of the potentially
negative consequences and
you talk about the story of a
shake, a Halim, uh,
and the lynching that took place that
was more or less driven by communication
messaging apps. Um, talk, talk
to me a little bit about that.
And this is really me putting my
Google news initiative hat on. Um,
the evolution of misinformation,
deep synthetic media, misinformation,
how you see that playing out in,
in India and the role and responsibility
that you feel, um, platforms,
uh, should, uh, should
take in addressing that.
Sure. So, uh, you know,
many of you have heard the stories of
lynchings that have taken place in India,
Hindu, Muslim related
violence, mob violence,
and much of this tends to stem from the
proliferation of fake news on Messaging
Apps, specifically whatsapp,
which is very popular in India,
but also other messaging apps in India.
I hesitate to put the blame squarely at
the place of messaging apps because it
is not as if rumors didn't spread before.
It is not as if there were not lynchings
and mob violence before technology.
Technology has just allowed for the
spread of these things faster and quicker
than was possible before.
Um,
what often happens is that people in
India are often not equipped in the same
way to decipher and deal with fake
news as people may be in the West.
And think of it this way. I mean, when
you all first started using the Internet,
that saying the late nineties,
you had a hotmail account and you would
get a chain mail and the chain May,
I would say, if you don't forward this
to 15 people, you'll be unlucky in love.
And you're laughing there.
I mean,
many of you have probably hit forward and
sent it to 15 people until a friend or
two says, Hey, this is stupid. Don't
do that. And then you don't do that.
But remember when I was talking about the,
the West's evolution
versus India's revolution.
So you all have evolved with the Internet
and you've evolved with your mistakes
and you've learned not to
make those mistakes over time.
So you are now more discerning consumers
of the Internet and our fake news,
and you're better able to
judge, you know, what is true,
what is false, what smells right,
what to forward, what not to.
Um, that's less so of the
case in India because again,
hundreds of millions of people are
discovering the Internet right now on
smartphones and they haven't built
the same nose for fake news. Um,
add to the fact that they are,
you know, not as privileged,
they don't have the same
levels of education. Um,
they don't have the same levels
of media literacy necessarily.
And um, very societies in India were
quite superstitious to begin with.
So you take all of those things together
with the power of social media to
amplify in a viral fashion and you
have a cocktail that's quite dangerous.
Um, it's a huge challenge for, I
think, tech companies to figure out,
but also society to figure out
and the government to figure out.
And as I was saying
earlier, I think, you know,
media literacy would be something
that I think tech companies,
if they can play a part
in helping communities
understand the basics of how to
decipher what is news, you know,
you know, who's funding it,
what's the dateline, is it written
by a human being? You know,
is it from a wire service? What is it? Um,
and then also just the basic pitfalls of
what happens when you forward something
basic. You know, how this
can be exponential, you know,
how to trust, how to verify.
That's very important.
It's a conversation that has just
begun to take place in India. Um,
but you know,
as a journalist,
I can tell you where the elections
around the corner in India,
this is an issue of grave concern.
A lot of things could go wrong before
Indian society figures out how to get it
right.
Yeah. And it's a, as you will know,
it's supposed to be quite the challenge
here in the states. So absolutely.
I imagine it's even,
it's even more even greater in India
on the same vein of like some of the
potential pitfalls of the smartphone
revolution. One of the parts of that,
one of the chapters that
really kind of shocked me,
it was like entirely news to me. Um,
concerns, just broadly a conversation on,
on sexuality and how it
shows up, uh, online. Um,
but you talk about kind of the advent of
very violent pornography and how that's
become readily accessible to,
um,
to hundreds of millions of
people, uh, in, in India. Um,
and you don't necessarily draw a direct
causal relationship between that and the
horrific, um, crimes that we've
seen in the last few years. Uh,
in India.
Uh,
but you do kind of allude to the fact
that there is something there that's worth
exploring based off of kind
of exploring that story,
do you feel like tech platforms have a
responsibility to curb or curtail that
sort of content?
This is a tough question because, um, I,
the last thing I would ever want
to advocate is curtailing, uh,
are censoring content.
And yet pornography is one of those
things where you have to wonder,
are people properly sensitized, deal with
it. And the reason why I say this is,
look,
growing up in the west is so different
from growing up in a village in India.
If you grow up here, you were sensitized
at a young age to the human body.
I mean, you go to the beach, you
see, you know, if you're a young boy,
you see a woman's legs at a very young
age. And you know, you talk about sex,
you go to coed schools, you have a
healthier relationship with sexuality.
Um, if you are a young boy in
rural India, you may have a very,
very different relationship with the
human body, with sexuality, with sex.
Um,
given that backdrop,
if your first experience of sexuality
is violent pornography and add to that,
the fact that this is not something
you can talk about with your family.
This is not something you
can talk about at school.
Do you have no way of deciphering
it and interpreting it?
There are real problems with that.
And you know, as a journalist, again,
when I was reporting in India,
one of the things that, uh,
the worst stories that I often had to
cover were very violent gang rapes,
um, and other types of
rape across the country.
And it was a deeply, deeply disturbing
thing to cover. And on the one hand,
of course, rape happens everywhere.
This is not uniquely a problem, uh,
unique to India.
It's not unique to any country,
but it did get me wondering,
you know,
is there a connection between
this explosion in pornography,
this explosion and access to
pornography? Because again, you know,
if you were a teenager in America of 10,
15 years ago,
you could hide a playboy
magazine under your mattress. Um,
for most Indians that was not an option.
The unit privacy works very
differently in India. Um,
access works very different
than you don't grow up.
Most Indians didn't grow up with a,
uh,
a TV and a VCR or a DVD player.
So the Internet changes everything.
A private viewing device
changes everything.
And I do wonder quite opening the
book whether there is a link between
pornography and rape, whether
there is a link between, um,
porn and, uh, you know, sexuality
in India. And I don't have answers.
I mean this is where I have to
be honest in that, you know,
a lot of the data shows that,
um, there may not be a link. Um,
but, but I sort of closed
that chapter, you know,
just very much in two minds.
And I think this is a conversation and a
debate that I think needs to take place
more widely in India
in a very open fashion.
And the reason why I say this again
is that sex and sexuality, uh,
you know,
is not new to India.
If you go back 500 years,
a thousand years,
you think again of the Kama Sutra and
think of temples in India that really
enshrined sex and sexuality.
Um,
so notions of openness about
sex should not be new to India,
but a notion of sort of prudishness was
introduced into Indian society through
colonization and, and you know, it was
more of a Victorian import, uh, you know,
think of the flowers and the
petticoat and the, you know,
so many things that, that didn't
even exist in India before that.
So it's, the water's a,
uh, quite muddied on this.
But I do think it's an issue that
that needs to be debated openly.
I wanted to pivot a little bit,
um,
to kind of the relationship between or
the role of the state and in some of
these technologies. Um, you,
you kind of talk very compellingly
about the fact that India is the world's
leader in digital blackouts
and specifically most of
that takes place in the
state of Kashmir.
And then you also kind of talk about
some of these very digital forward
initiatives like other,
for example,
which of sound incredible in terms of
their potential if we can get it right.
But,
um,
there've been conversations around data
breach and privacy leaks from that. The,
you know, it's the kind of theme
that percolates throughout the book.
Like this is an incredible
technology that we should,
that can do all these
incredible things and uh,
and really addressing and
solving real problems for a
lot of people. Uh, but when,
but we have to be careful about
like the state's role. Um,
and particularly trusting a state with
data and privacy would be great to get
your sense of, do you, I mean,
having written the book now, like,
do you feel like the state in India is
equipped to properly manage and handle
this data in a way that ensures that
we get the better end of the potential?
I don't know, is the
honest answer. I mean,
what we do know is that everyone
needs checks and balances,
including the state, including big
corporations. So, for example, um,
uh, if you haven't read this yet, um,
India has more internet shutdowns
than any other country on earth. Uh,
Syria and Iraq are two and three.
And what this means is
that at any given moment,
the state can just switch off the
internet. So it basically has, uh,
the, the biggest mobile provides value to
providers on speed dial and it can call
them and say, all right, in this
particular area, shut down the Internet.
This often happens in Kashmir officer
encounters with terrorists. Uh,
and the reason, the logic is that,
again, to use the car analogy,
if there's a car crash right outside here,
the police would likely
cordon off the street.
And so digitally speaking,
if there is a clash between the
police and militants in Kashmir,
um, the, the authorities would
shut off the Internet so that,
uh, militants wouldn't
be able to, uh, you know,
send out imagery on social media
or seek help or anything like that.
Now on the one hand,
there's a clear a use for this,
but on the other hand
there is immense misuse,
especially if it isn't properly codified.
You know,
under what circumstances is a
government allowed to impose a shutdown?
Who makes the decision?
Is there any accountability?
Is there any recourse if
a wrong decision was made?
And then linked to all
of that is over time.
So cushy the state of Kashmir for example,
um,
it lost hundreds of millions of dollars
in lost business and this is according
to a study by Brookings because the
Internet was shut down for months.
So, uh, you know, those are
clear examples of the state.
Um, you can call it overreaching,
you can call it, you know,
taking a draconian approach to
dealing with a problem. But again,
for all the good that the Internet and
the proliferation of smartphones can do
in a place like India,
there is so much grey area and so much
of sort of new areas of regulation that
that haven't really been covered
or discussed in the public space.
And Internet shutdowns
is chief among them. Um,
[inaudible] is a very interesting
topic in and of itself. Um,
for those of you don't know,
that's the,
the biometric ID system in
India that has now signed up.
I think it's about 1.2 billion people.
It's a,
a system that basically
allows people to say, I am me.
So it's an ID card,
uh,
with fingerprints and retinal
scans included. And um,
this is part of a very
polarized debate in India.
There are people who will say that this
could have immense positive impacts in
terms of, um, you know,
people being able to have an an id
to open bank accounts to open it,
to get cell phone lines to get subsidies
from the government, so on and so forth.
But there are many who will also tell
you a critics who will say that, um,
this could be misused by the state.
It could be, there could be leakages,
there could be hacks. Uh, you
can't change your fingerprint.
So once you lose them to someone else,
you're in trouble. So on and so forth.
I tend to fall somewhere between,
in the middle of that debate where I
think you can't deny that there is immense
potential to this.
And I think the government on the other
hand needs to address the critics and
openly acknowledge that
there have been leaks. And,
and this again is where the private
sector could, could help, uh,
in terms of how to plug those leaves,
how to have better security and how to
be more upfront about where things stand,
better communication all around which
I think the private sector has immense
experience with [inaudible].
One of,
um,
one of the striking chapters is on a
topic that folks who followed it in
politics over the last couple of years
would be well aware of demonetization.
What's interesting about that particular
chapter was you kind of follow the
story of this auto rickshaw driver and
kind of his journey through dealing with
the aftermath of demonetization.
There's a line around you wondered whether
or not he'd ever be able to learn how
to use a smartphone and really,
um,
really be able to join in this
increasingly digital economy.
What responsibility do you think society
in tech companies have for those who in
the short term or medium term, maybe even
long term, are being left behind by the,
this increasing wave of digitization?
So you can contrast fooled with the story.
With the story of the survey.
She was an auto rickshaw driver.
I met in Delhi and followed
around for two years now.
And he knows deep down that he
just cannot use a smartphone.
He can't bring himself to use a
smartphone, doesn't understand it,
is very intimidated by technology that
can't even afford it to begin with.
Um,
and the reason why that even came up is,
um, during demonetization, which
for those of you don't know,
it was a moment where the government
recalls the two highest currency
denomination notes from the market,
which was 86% of all cash and
replaced it with two other notes.
The reason being that they wanted a to
get rid of so called black money in the
system, which is money that hasn't, uh,
on which income tax hasn't been paid
and be to move India towards digital
payments. Um, but in that chaotic moment,
which most economists worth their
salt have decried as you know,
a horrendous stupid decision which has
cost India as much as 2% of its GDP.
But in that chaotic moment, many
people suffered for their livelihoods,
including surveys. This auto rickshaw
driver because all of his, his, uh,
rides were paid for in cash and
because people didn't have cash,
he wasn't making any money.
So he was really struggling.
And in that moment when I was interviewing
him for CNN, I asked him, well, hey,
why don't you use Uber? Uh,
why don't you sign up for Ola,
which is Uber is Indian
equivalent and competitor.
And that's where it all came up. He just
was very intimidated by technology. Um,
didn't have a smartphone and felt
like this was just not for him. And,
and I contrast that story with food,
with these because it's one thing
for us to think of technology as,
you know,
if you just build it and people will come,
that's not necessarily going to happen,
especially in places like India where
there so many barriers and think of not
just people like survey shoe young,
I mean he's in his twenties and
should really be able to learn.
Um, the think of older people in
India. India has about, you know,
250 million people who are
over the age of 55, 60.
And for those people,
technology is very intimidating.
It's very hard to just be
given a smartphone and then
learn how to use it and
learn how to communicate and
learn how to use apps. So, um,
that space was very important
for me to explore as well. It's,
it's sort of a,
a counterpoint to the narrative that
tech is necessarily going to transform
India, not as much as tech
will transform. India.
I think India will also transform
tech. I think, you know, there,
there India has all these unique
ways of dealing with tech. You know,
Indians are still,
uh,
much more comfortable with cash than
they are with digital payments. Uh,
Indians preferred you Wilson phones over
single sim phones because they like to
switch between service providers.
Indians prefer prepaid Saturday to
contracts instead of postpaid because they
don't trust large companies to give
them good service. Not only that,
large companies don't trust
them to pay up on time,
so they prefer prepaid options as well.
So for all of those reasons,
India is just a unique market.
Um,
and a very large market
that I think, uh, is,
is going to evolve.
And change and its own very special ways.
And um, my last question before
we open it up for Q and. A. Um,
so given that,
given how unique India is and,
and the reality is that we've
unpacked here, uh, so far,
let's say hypothetically
you were a product manager
overseeing android or you're
in charge of building out products
for the next billion users in India.
Um,
what are some of the things that you'd
keep in mind or that you would feel are,
uh, are considerations that would be
front and center and how you approached,
um, rolling out those products and
those sorts of products that you built?
That's a great question.
Uh, I'm sure Google is doing
all of these things already,
but I would,
if I was a product manager,
I would bring on board people
like salvation food. But the,
I would bring on board
people who are not literate,
people who have never used any technology
before and see what kinds of problems
they're encountering. A, I would,
the English market in India is
already very well served. Um,
it's the Indian language market
in the Bengali, Tamil Telugu.
So on and so forth that
is still underserved.
And I would explore how those
users engage with the Internet,
what they need,
uh,
what they're struggling with
and then links to all of that.
I would really focus on digital
literacy and media literacy.
I think there is with the great power
that companies like Google have in places
like India comes a responsibility
I believe to help people
navigate things that
could do immense good but can do
immense harm as well. And so, you know,
stepping in where the state has failed,
you know, to help people understand,
you know, to learn how to engage
with news, to learn what is right,
what is wrong, to verify,
um, to build that,
you know, that inner sense of, uh,
that, that aptitude of being
able to gauge, you know,
what is real and what is fake.
That will be one of the great
challenges for Indian society.
And if I was able to do that,
um, as a product manager,
I think that's one of the things I would
spend a lot of time thinking about.
And I think whoever is able to fix that
in the private sector would have done an
immense,
immense service to a place like India.
Because you know,
India doesn't have to repeat
the mistakes of the west India.
India's path could be different through
technology and we all talk about the
word leap frog. Uh, and India
will leapfrog in many ways.
It will leap frog credit
cards. It will leap frog, uh,
so many different things that
the west has evolved through.
But leapfrog isn't
necessarily a good thing.
You can leap frog to a bad place as well.
That's where I think the private sector
can really help with and sort of speed
up that learning process and not assume
that that learning processes already in
place
shouldn't be long. Open it up for
audience questions. There are two mikes.
Just wonder and wonder if
folks want to start queuing up.
First of all, thank you.
Very, very interesting talk.
I think throughout this talk, most
of the, or even or even completely,
we've contrasted India with,
with the West,
the United States specifically.
And, uh, um, you know,
there are some ways where,
you know,
we share similar problems when one thing
went obvious thing that we did talk
about was um, uh, sexual content online.
I think even in the United States,
uh,
the availability of problematic content
online far outpaces the availability of
good sexual education in most of this
country. Okay. It's just as an example.
So I am wondering what, um, uh,
what lessons have you learned from your
exploration of how India got connected,
uh, that might apply to
the United States as well?
Wow. So the other way around. Um,
well that's a great question.
Um,
I think because India is discovered
all of these things later,
it is sort of learning from the
West's mistakes as it goes along.
But in terms of lessons from India,
um,
you know,
one takeaway I think would be that
cultures use technology in ways
that are very unique to them.
And I think, especially for, um,
for investors here, you know, anyone who's
dealing with products that are global,
I think it's very important to
see each culture, each community,
each as having very unique ways
of dealing with technology.
And so for example, the, when
I was talking about cash, um,
you know, Indians, Indians, what I
like to call a very low trust society.
And,
and that's because Indians almost always
just assume that anything that could go
wrong in the system will go wrong.
Uh,
Indians don't show up for meetings on
time because they don't expect the other
person to show up on time.
Uh,
Indians like to pay for things in cash
because they think something could go
wrong with a credit
card. Um, so, you know,
cash on delivery is a very
big thing in India. Um, uh,
Amazon's big competitor in India,
Flipkart began as a company that was
delivering books to people and then those
customers would pay for it in
cash at their doorsteps. Um,
and the reason why I'm explaining
this as a lesson for America is that,
um,
you know,
each market will develop in its own way.
And will have its own sort of unique
relationship with how technology develops
and how it should be
used. Um, that said, uh,
I wish I could tell you that India for
all of its great connections with faith
and religion, you know, India was
the birthplace of for religions.
It was the birthplace of yoga.
I wish I could tell you that Indians have
a better relationship with screens and
they don't, uh, I think
uh, addictions as much as,
as much as it screen addiction
as a problem here in the west.
It is becoming so in India.
And so in that sense, uh,
India really has no lessons
to offer. Uh, and, and the,
the solution to that problem
would have to be a global one.
Thank you.
Hi Robin. Thanks for joining us and
sharing your thoughts, aren't you?
To go a little bit more into that,
you briefly mentioned regulation,
regulation of technology and the
foreign was this Indian company dynamic.
And I've seen many a stories recently
about the common wanting to change how
things are and the status quo of things
like their localization, stuff like that.
So I just wanted to hear your thoughts
on how things look right now and what you
think will happen in the future.
Like is India going to become another
China in terms of foreign companies not
being able to play on the same level?
I mean,
I don't think India can become another
China and I don't think even the
government wants to do that. China's just
such a different market to begin with.
Uh, their Internet is, you
know, almost like one language.
They have apps that are, as you all know,
an entire ecosystem in and of itself.
India's evolution with the Internet has
been so different. Number one, you know,
India has more than 200 million
English language users. Um,
right from the start.
Uh,
Western companies were allowed in and
became the leaders of the Indian internet,
Google being first among them,
but also Amazon and Uber and so many
other companies that made it big in India
quite early.
I think what you're seeing now more
recently in terms of regulation is,
is India and this
government's reaction to, um,
Western companies having such
a large slice of the pie.
And so for example, in the
ecommerce space, you know,
if the Indian government is restricting,
uh,
the amount that Western companies can
own and accompany or the amount of
business that they can
do in a certain space,
I think they're doing that primarily just
to protect local companies from being
able to survive and stay in the game.
Uh,
I don't think it will ever rise to the
levels of either China or even sort of
the protectionism that we
saw in India in the 80s. Um,
because India,
I think one of the things you
must see about India is that,
you know, every politician, uh,
every regulator looks
to 1991 as the urine,
which the Indian economy really opened
up and benefited from opening up.
I just cannot see India
going back on that. Uh,
I cannot see even this government, uh,
you know, stepping back on that front,
I think they realize that, uh, opening
up is where, where their strength lies.
Uh, and I think they also realized
that the market isn't static.
It's growing so fast that there's
enough space for everyone.
Thanks for being here.
I remained largely ignorant of India.
Short of some stories from Maroon about
his personal travels before this talk.
And I'm very interested in,
you mentioned the way that India
will change technology. Um,
is there infrastructure in place
for, uh, either developers in India,
are phone makers in India to really
learn at scale how to build better
technology for those that are
often overlooked in the west, um,
poor people beyond just the cost of phone
and sort of reducing access to entry,
actually building technology that serves,
you know,
at the APP level or one layer further.
Um,
some of those more rural and
offering separated populations?
Yeah, there is, that's a great question.
I think most of it is led by
the private sector again, um,
if you look at, um, so I,
I coming back to education,
I talk about uh,
an Indian company and my chapter on
education, it's called aches step,
which means one step and
they have developed, um,
essentially they like to think
of themselves as, you know,
for example,
the Uber of primary education where
they've created a platform where other
developers can jump in and
create multilingual content.
For primary schoolers are primary school
teachers to be able to use for their
students.
And it really is a great
example of sort of,
you know, Indian tech developers
using their technologies.
And this was inspired by odd Har.
Uh,
so it's sort of an open stack kind of
system that allows other companies to
create other things around it.
I think of all the heart itself,
the biometric ID system, which
is Indian, it's indigenous,
uh, it's Indian run Indian engineers. Um,
and this was the government's initiative,
but it was led by you know,
private sector, techie a none the Nilekani
for those of you who don't know him,
uh, who found cofounded
emphasis. Um, but again,
the basic logic being that,
uh,
you can harness Indian strengths
and Indian workers, uh,
to create these open platforms,
systems that could then plug
into other aspects, you know,
it could plug into the banking
sector, it can plug in to, uh,
the government subsidy schemes
and so on and so forth.
So I think that space is where
most of the innovation is taking,
taking place. Um, more than any
other space, I would say. Uh,
you know, if, if you look at other
spaces like search or messaging,
I would argue that the most innovation
is taking place in the west or maybe in
China and India is development
on that front is more derivative.
My question was more towards the future.
So if you look at India right now, uh,
it has,
the country is totally not for you to
share the highest or a large fraction of
the population living
in rural and rural blizzardous
up and out at the vast.
Okay. Talking about it in
the next decade or two,
how are say hydrogen intelligence,
we'll check with jobs. Uh,
and I would still assume that maybe a
showing orthorexia could be as profitable
as a self driving car for a company
that wants to make it. Yeah.
So do you have any thoughts about what,
uh,
how a country like India that a suit
behind in terms of technology and in terms
of,
in this industrial exesion would be
affected a say 20 years down the line?
It's a great question. Uh, and I try to
deal with this a little bit in the book.
So there are two things going
on. On the one hand, um,
the rise of smartphones will
lead in the immediate future,
I think to immense job creation.
So if you think of the ecommerce market,
which is going to grow leaps
and bounds in India, um,
the kinds of jobs that you create with
the ecommerce market are ideally suited
to the Indian labor profiles.
So you've got delivery jobs,
you've got packing jobs,
warehousing jobs.
Those are exactly the kinds of jobs
that rural Indian men mostly are exactly
primed for a, they don't
need more education. Uh,
those are the kinds of
jobs they're looking.
They're relatively well paid for
what they're looking for. Uh,
so there are enough studies out there
that show that those kinds of jobs will
create, you know, tens of
millions of jobs over the next 10,
15 years. That's sort of the
shorter term perspective.
And then there are many other stories
of, you know, like there's an Indian, uh,
version of Linkedin for blue collar
workers. It's called Baba jobs,
which was then bought over by quicker.
And basically it sort of connects people,
uh, who are seeking a certain type of
job to that particular type of employer.
You know, if you're a Domino's pizza
and India for example, um, you know,
you are looking for delivery man,
the standards for selecting a
delivery man is, are pretty low.
Like if you show up for the job interview,
you're going to get the job.
So the real challenge there is
connecting the secret to the employer and
technology will fix a lot of those issues.
So in the short term,
I think there's an immense benefits.
The longer term is where the
troubles come around, uh, as, um,
these giant warehouses get automated
as deliveries get automated as,
uh, cars get automated. The thing is,
it's hard for me to imagine those
things happening in India the way I can
imagine them happening in the West.
See,
it's one thing to imagine a
drone delivering a package to,
you know,
this giant house in Pasadena where it
just drops it off in the garden delivery
done.
But can you imagine the same drone
delivering the same product to a slum in
Mumbai where,
you know,
you're trying to hover over this tiny
shack and they're like 200 children
playing around there and then
one of them grabs the package,
someone else grabs the
drone and know that,
that that's the end of
the model right there. Um,
it's hard also to imagine, um, you know,
the algorithm that would
work for, uh, you know,
automated driving in India.
I used to drive in India and you know,
you're navigating not just roads and cars,
but you're navigating people in cows,
you know, so, and other animals
and it's hard to imagine,
uh, automation really working, uh,
in these tiny narrow lanes where
it takes immense on ingenuity,
you know, just scream and shout and
corral support for your car to get out.
So on the one hand,
I think when these things eventually
get automated in India, um,
you know, we will see immense
job losses. I just, I,
I can't bring myself around to seeing
that moment. I can't imagine it.
I don't know if you guys can Google, but
it's, India is a very different market.
Yeah.
And it speaks to our responsibility to
kind of be thoughtful about some of those
consequences before they really manifest.
Or last audience question.
Thanks for coming. Thank
you. You mentioned a couple
times about the biometric ID system.
Um,
but you also mentioned that
and he has a low trust society.
Has there been any worry or discussion
about adopting some of what the Chinese
government does is doing?
Using the vitamins are consistent?
There has been a, I think the debate
has been restricted mostly to, uh,
sort of more elite policy circles and
amongst journalists and civil society.
And I don't imagine that,
you know,
out of the 1.2 billion people
who've signed up, you know,
I would imagine the vast majority haven't
really thought too much about privacy.
And you have to think again of
where they're coming from. Uh,
most have come from a place where they
had no form of id or driver's license,
certainly no passport,
um, no way of getting, uh,
access to government
subsidies or products.
So this was a big leap and it was
a useful lead for many people.
And despite being a low trust society,
it's very telling that they were able to
invest so much trust in the government
in the hope of something better.
Um,
and that speaks to the potential for
technology in India and how much,
how much hope people have
for what technology could
do and how it could better
their lives. But as I was saying
earlier that there are many,
many things that could go wrong and,
and that is a debate that needs to be had.
It is, uh, something that the government
needs to be more open, uh, about,
uh, there certainly have been
massive leaks and you know,
fessing up to them nice and early
and being transparent would serve the
government. Well, I mean the,
you know, everything has leaks.
It's owning up to them and dealing with
them that eventually we'll win people's
trust I think. So that's a longer
journey for India. Sorry, go ahead.
Yeah.
So just to clarify.
So overall it's been very beneficial
and the risks are like what are the more
immediate risks if not
for odd Har?
Yeah,
I think the immediate risks are a,
uh,
large scale leaks be the information
from those leaks being harnessed in ways
that are particularly insidious. So, um,
it could be voter fraud,
it could be a impersonation,
it could be opening fake accounts.
Um,
there's a range of things that one could
see happening based on leaked biometric
ids.
All of that said one advantage
of this system is that a,
it is a government controlling it,
not a company and B,
it is data that is fairly dumb.
I mean it is your id,
but it doesn't have your browsing
history. It doesn't have your, uh,
I sort of preferences. It's hard to sell
that to an ad firm and see, you know,
it's, it's not an immense value to
someone else, uh, in the way that,
uh, other leaks that we've seen from,
from other companies could be. Um,
Facebook sneaks for example, to
came Cambridge Analytica. Um,
so in that sense,
I think the potential for odd,
hard to be dangerous is less so than,
uh,
other leaks that we now know
about, um, from the private sector.
All of that sad, um, one
shouldn't dismiss, uh,
the what, what could go wrong
with that higher. And I think, um,
you know, it's, again,
it's a conversation that needs to be
had more openly and robustly in India.
Thank you all for being here.
Thank you so much.